- The horns are cool.
- Yeah, but they're done like expletive.
Look at them, expletive horrible.
- Hi, and we are professionals from the tattoo industry.
- And we're gonna be reviewing tattoos from the movies.
Here we go, Harry Potter.
- I definitely thought that this was a kid's movie.
- Badly done tattoo, horrible.
- Yeah, not a good tattoo at all.
- Great movie.
- Splotchy and blurry.
- Is the skull snake thing pooping?
- We have a shot from Eastern Promises.
- All I can say is scary.
- Yeah, he looks jacked up.
- Yeah, you can tell that he's been to prison.
You don't get those in a shop for sure.
- If I saw a dude walking down the street
with Russian tattoos like that I would avoid him.
- Dude, where's my car, yes!
- Greatest tattoos ever.
I don't care about the quality of them,
it was one of the greatest tattoo scenes in a movie.
- I actually don't think these
tattoos are that bad, honestly.
- This is probably, like, something
you would get for your first tattoo
and they're laughing at each other.
- Oh, I like this tattoo.
This is from Stranger Than Fiction.
- Tattoo's not bad.
- Very well done.
- Yes.
- Pirates of the Caribbean.
- Caribbean, yeah.
- Your tattoos need to be big enough
so that your detail doesn't splotch up like that.
- The tattoo looks like your typical, like,
1950s old school tattoo, sun-beaten.
- Memento, damn, it's like, "Come on, dude."
- He looks like one of the Backstreet Boys
and he's like, "I got tattoos finally."
- Get a pack of Post-Its.
- The lettering is really off.
That's really bad.
- I would hate a client that came in and was like,
"Can we put the lettering backwards
"so I can read it in the mirror?"
- Black Swan tattoo on the back.
- Are those flowers?
- Yeah, those are Calla Lilies.
- That's impressive, that you knew what those were.
- Everybody knows what they are.
- No one knew what they were.
- Not done well.
- Nah, no contrast at all.
- Whoa, that's me, Moana.
- They look pretty cool.
I like them.
- I think that they are composed really well on the piece.
People come in all the time asking for this stuff,
not realizing that there is a meaning behind everything.
- I know you've seen this movie.
Don't come in and say that you want something like this
and tell us it's gonna take two hours, okay?
Try, like, twelve.
- I guess it's supposed to be, like,
robotic wings out of tribal?
- Oh, God, that looks like barbed wire.
- Suicide Squad.
(laughing)
The Joker letters are very nice.
- And the Ha-Ha-Ha up top is good.
- Red Dragon.
- This looks like a horribly done garage tattoo.
- I just don't like the shading.
It's like the guy was rushing to finish this.
- That's it.
That was fun.
(upbeat energetic music)